[Musique]
alors bonsoir je viens pour la signature
de l'appartement exactement de la mer
d'un notaire mon frère regardez il est
de plus en plus bon s'il a atteint sur
hot à la barbe de tous situés doucy
doute partout malek
il ya un changement fanfare après malek
cédric alors écoutez moi bien c'est pas
parce qu'on aime l'amitié voilà oui y'a
pas de fins de phrases
alors vous savez que le week-end dernier
vous étiez en tunisie bien sûr vous
savez on a encore en mémoire c'est vrai
dans ces le pays du jasmin et c'est vrai
que cyril hanouna vous avez été reçu là
bas royalement quoi c'est un truc de fou
on n'a que de faux noms et d'isabelle
morini-bosc quand elle va faire des
dédicaces dans un maison de retraite
cette fois la même chose j'ai donc
participé à l'équivalent tunisienne 50
minutes inside reste c'est vrai oui
alors je vous remets à serena le laurier
du gars qui y perd convaincant quand il
donne une interview à bata scellé la
nonna mal cochan lui c'est le nikos
aliagas tunisien divona funny interview
cyril où vous avez expliqué que vous
détestiez une chose dans l'émission la
vulgarité dans la culture tunisienne
moi j'ai remarqué il n'aime pas mine de
rien par les deux de deux sexes de
guerre contre les cylons était vulgaire
déjà ma mère regarderai pas parce que ma
mère dès que je dis un petit un mot
vulgaire ou un truc comme ça tout de
suite
elle m'appelle andy rautins 10 a
commencé pour moi jamais l'on n'est pas
en jeu parmi de 5,6 de chez vous
mais ma table même aujourd'hui jamie
m'arrive devient un gros mot de bande
passante de connard à l'état gueule
touche à ton cul tu auras des verrues
excusez moi chercher la petite bête un
petit peu un petit peu croix sur trois
gros mots en novembre oui j'ai pris que
trois vidéos et avec trois oui
franchement up qui franchement comme
jette la première pierre cros il n'a
jamais craqué l'adie en faire un
craquage par semaine
voilà bah je le fais je le fais par
balmont il ya un autre braquage qui
arrive ah bah oui parce que tout faire
on poste un programme unique
alors pourquoi parce que c'est la seule
émission on entend l'animateur menacé un
chroniqueur de le taz et regarder
comment benjamin castaldi est hyper
choqué et après le zumba bas proposé le
zoom casta
[Musique]
si c'est pas ça oui je suis vous plaît
taisez-vous parce que j'ai pas je vais
vous depasser vous je peux le faire
on ne résout rien avec la violence
croyez moi et je sens c'est quelque
chose dont l'armée alors ils sont en
train de rembourser duchaussoy s'est
passé oui je suis vous pouvez tester
vous parce que j'ai pas je vais vous
depasser vous je peux me regarder
hélas hélas il nous fait ce qu'on
appelle dans le métier et loire ce qu'on
appelle une menthe au nahd à menton a
avancé une menthe au nahd et où il
regardé regarder et et alors grichka il
est aussi choqué mais ça se voit moins
mille écus choi les quelque chose sur
mon frigidaire
moi je vais m j'allais mettre quoi sur
votre frigidaire les mutilations votre
régime à ben jawad autorise vous avez
dit je ne sais pas à quoi ça va m'amener
mais on trouve
[Rires]
et ce qui y est qu elle lui ça rigolait
lui il est en train de décoller sa
formule 1 qui va dans l'air swiss
hamilton de la manne
je vais essayer de tenir un petit peu
plus alors on va s'y pressent de virer
nouveau qui vient d'avoir un tableau
d'honneur merci bouffon bas vendée sur
celui de juste après la touche pas à mon
poste ouvert à tous y avait des missions
de la télé de florence foresti
ah ouais bon ce forestier on l'avait
redit ça c'était une webdiffusion alors
ça je vous le dis je vous explique quand
on n'a plus rien sur ces vite on met la
télé de quelqu'un voilà à le voir demain
c'est un inédit c'est la télé des
bodin's oui hélas très fort oui parce
que la télé de riquet la télé florence
foresti frère c'est que dit ma mère un
père qui est dans le creux commentaires
se rater de même heure il a 22 ans à
l'école qui parle de lui demain bien sûr
on l'a dit alors il ya la productrice
qui écoutent pas ce que dit qu'ils me
dis demain c'est un inédit parce qu'à
mon avis elle doit être à côté de la
chaîne qui écoute en rien non plus
question raisons qui font rien qui sont
en train d'envoyer des trucs sur un
stage sur sms que je les connais foule
dit la chaîne henry je vous expliquer
comment n'est ce pas alors mais je
racontais sujet explique le nail en
souvenir parce que jouer je raconte tout
à perdre elle va continuer à boire c'est
votre ennemi chabot est à poker est
expliqué j'aimerais expliquer la faire
c'est que la chaîne comment ça se passe
tous les jours il envoie quelqu'un pour
vérifier ce qui se passe dans l'émission
donc la personne de la chaîne elle va en
régie est à noter que truffaut mes
frères comme tout le monde veut venir
parce qu'ils disent à 17 heures je me
barre du bureau ils prennent leur part
au sud où ils traînent dans les couloirs
à manger des tags à dallas il
des michaud comme on perd voilà à la
presse yves horent megiddo baudets
célèbre ring est vraiment ils ont tendu
à et comme il entend de rien il n'est
plus rien il dit c'est un truc qui est
passé il ya deux heures donc écoutez moi
bien si c'est pour faire sa rentrée
directement chez vous on vous donnera le
dvd je remercie donc les angoisses quand
même c'est à gré mais ils sont très
sympas mais sinon je vais arrêter d
michoko voilà donc ils sont là donc ils
m'ont dit de dire que c'est un inédit
demain d'accord ok ballon s'il continue
sur la tête de ma mère y parle encore
une fois d'inédits je dis que c'est
arrivé donc la télé de fraude de faux
récit avec florence foresti quai par les
humoristes préférés des français avec
popeck et roland magdane et la fin nous
voir à tous au moment de rendre
l'antenne benjamin était magnifique
je lui remets l'oreille du seul
animateur français qui ne connaît pas le
prénom de florence foresti
[Applaudissements]
si en exclusivité j'ai les noms des
prochaines émissions qu'on va lancer
berrahma castlevania l'iphone ouvert à
tous vous retrouvez donc sur ces vies
très prochainement la télé de jazz de
blues la télé de jean claude gérard et
bien sûr la télé de mohamed baffie bien
sûr molteni jamais su pourquoi tu fais
ça toi tu as tellement de prénom de meuf
qui trotte dans la tête c'est comme chez
lui le soir
madame appel delphine défaite quand même
trente jours pour être au top
jamais un mot plus haut que l'autre
voilà merci ça veut dire il faut
vraiment qu'on parle je suis pas comment
est ce possible que depuis le début de
cette émission depuis 19h vous avez dans
votre petite tête
le prénom delphine qui vous trotte et
que vous dites constamment à la mesure
où les retire l union et une ré ce qui
s'est passé il ya une association
d'idées star oui laurie il soit on a
l'habitude d'avoir une miss france ti
qui s'appelle des devises alors tout
simplement médaille il n'allait pas
chercher les d'histoire là où il y en a
pas ben je vous dis occupez-vous de
patoche ça sera déjà beaucoup parce que
pato ce que vous êtes en direct et je
peux vous dire que tous les soirs entre
19h et 21h oui et c'est plus qu'un repli
[Applaudissements]
l'adie patoche lui il connaît mon prénom
et se trompent
bah ouais vous dise la fidélité c'est
pas son fort heureusement il a une bonne
mémoire
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
nous regarde d'ailleurs en courant vers
le tour de 21h30
y'a pas de chocolat ce soir donc elle va
rentrer rapidement
voilà merci vous savez que la semaine
dernière on a reçu les jumeaux les plus
célèbres du monde arrive et hervé noël
souviennent bien sûr je veux bien sûr
parler d'igor et grichka bogdanoff
il y aurait chaque camp le même médecin
généraliste que magali bertin a dit
généralement général voit que lille est
que les femmes qui prennent pas pour les
boxeurs surtout pas baba gallé vous êtes
mais l'addition
merci c'est gentil et je vous le dis et
je vous vois vous êtes dans mon axe
certain culot ne regardant les attend
vraiment bravo bravo à eux
c'est pas parce que voilà si on n'est
pas tout si j'ai des généralistes
moyenne werder qui n'a pas eu le bac
avec mention mais les bogdanoff ce sigle
avec mon tour assez bien j'en suis bien
du coup j'ai fait tout ce qu'ils avaient
ils avaient leur bac avec mon ton ça
passe pas ses parents et avec mon temps
c'est pas mal de baguette il essayait
j'essayais font écho les scientifiques
nous ont fait plusieurs fois la semaine
dernière et encore une fois cyril vous
avez bien accueilli ces bogdanov skype
je vous promets encore le laurier du
thar bogda non qu'encore année encore
c'est si si
[Musique]
précédemment dans le tarn bogda le père
igor et grichka bien sûr avec ça vous
fait un pari menton donc webley mentaux
n'est jamais sorti lauréat de sciences
po peut en vertu de la voir le menton
firent en réunion de matha ya des fans
avec siri qui nous font marrer mais une
fois qu'il faut les assumer face à igor
et grichka pour l'animal c'est plus
raisonnable on aura question pour un
menton nombreux cyril avait réinvité les
bogdanoff car vous aviez un grand regret
ne pas avoir fait plus de blagues sur
eux alors voici le tard bordas de leur
tournée menton vous pouvez assurer à
tout le monde que nous nous mentons pas
je sache c'est connu depuis des années
on s'est connu un concours de je te
tiens tu me tiens par la barbichette
igor et grichka ils ont travaillé toute
la nuit
oui il y en a pas le temps de se coincer
[Applaudissements]
c'est mes potes et je vous dis on se dit
tout ils ont beaucoup dumas mais c'est
ça sans régler mais on peut rigoler pas
aux heures d'été comme à toute la soirée
je te jure
j'étais chez nous on a regardé la télé
sur ses vrais échanges avec le monde
je les adore ses des superphones aussi
il son sac je me permets un missile
franchement regardez
benjamin est pareil ils ont eu le pro
très bien on savait que lundi les
chroniqueurs ne sont pas bien parce
qu'ils savent que je vais dévoiler ce
qui parle beaucoup et ceux qui ne
parlent quasiment jamais pendant
l'émission mais là ça y est ça commence
à stresser
la fin de saison approche qu'il faut se
montrer pour pouvoir signer l'année
prochaine après attention vous mais
peut-être parlait peu et bien plus tôt
que beaucoup aient mal et ça regarde que
de leur mobile a tout compris par
exemple il ya fait une demi-heure
pourrait produire ça va bien superbe
vous savez ce que au québec et leurs
idées 19h55 les gr 46 et encore alors
tunisien des caps une heure et alors ça
va tu as matelots d'être content d'être
là suit dans le classement a peut-être
une grande chance c'est le classement de
ceux qui parlent le moins à ceux qui
parlent le plus tôt et voilà c'est parti
mais ce que matthieu delormeau a été
détrôné tout c'est donc ces nouvelles
éditions de n'oubliez pas de prendre la
parole
[Musique]
on commence avec en bas du classement
celui qui a le plus oublié de prendre la
parole la semaine dernière benjamin
castaldi avec seulement 28 interventions
il a pris la parole une fois toutes les
dix sept minutes
à la 9e place du classement le seul mec
du public qui est payé tous les soins
pour regarder la télé doc gynéco avec 34
interventions toutes plus exceptionnel
les unes que les autres dont celle ci a
donc il est quoi du classement la
deuxième place avec 54 prises de parole
celle qui n'est pas margot robbie mais
margot robot valérie bénaïm
et enfin numéro avec 83 intervention la
semaine dernière celui qui a le moins
oublié de prendre la parole et jean
miché mai mais beaucoup de crème et tout
ça se produit c'est dû à peu près une
heure et demie ouais tu fais pas le
peeling de la nuit prochaine sur toutes
les interventions c'est le best of que
vous avez pris d'un oui c'est le
meilleur de lui michel en une semaine
et bah merci le monde
[Applaudissements]